ja nicht mehr lange dann geht die ära
merkel zu ende 16 jahre war sie dann
bundeskanzlerin viele junge menschen
kennen gar keinen anderen regierungschef
und trotzdem trotz dieser langen zeit
kennen wir angela merkel wirklich die
private angela merkel gestern abend hat
sie bei einer podiumsdiskussion seltene
einblicke gegeben und unser kollege jan
schäfer kann uns jetzt davon erzählen
guten morgen guten morgen waren das für
eine veranstaltung also angela merkel
hatte gestern die chance war eingeladen
ein bisschen über sich privat zu
sprechen es ging unter anderem um die
frage um ihr kleidungsstil es ging auch
um ein sehr persönliches erlebnis einen
persönlichen moment vor zwei jahren
starb ihre mutter und jeder der schon
mal einen nahen verwandten ein
elternteil verloren hat kann natürlich
mitfühlen wie das ist wenn man eltern
verliert oder auch geschwister oder
vielleicht sogar kinder und da hat
angela merkel einmal auch die tür ihres
inneren weit aufgemacht um zu erzählen
wie sie sich eigentlich selbst fühlt
weil sie drei tage später bereits eine
regierungserklärung halten muss und da
ist man natürlich eigentlich mit ganz
ganz anderen dingen beschäftigt da lässt
man das leben seiner mutter das
gemeinsame leben die schönen erlebnisse
die traurige erlebnisse einfach nochmal
revue passieren ist eigentlich mit den
gedanken ganz woanders und muss dann im
bundestag stehen und den deutschen
erklären warum europa wichtig ist oder
eben nicht also klar dass auch direkt
mal anhören wirklich sehr emotionale
worte
also ich habe es jedenfalls immer so
gemacht dass ich mir dann auch meinen
diesen raum da hab ich dann auch
niemanden reingelassen der da nicht
hingehört und
es ging
wenn sie dann drei tage nach dem tod der
eltern wegen der regierungserklärung
halten müssen oder so dass es man kann
jetzt nicht einfach sagen ich bin dann
mal weg und das ist schon auch etwas
sehr spezielles und da aber es gibt auch
sehr viel verständnis von menschen die
das dann auch verstehen dass man da
seinen raum braucht
gar nicht warum plötzlich so viel
privates
also die kanzlerin geht mit ihrem
privatleben sehr dosiert um das haben
wir den 16 letzten jahren immer wieder
gemerkt aber gerade vor wahlen gab es
immer wieder momente in denen sie
beispielsweise auch mal erklärte dass
sie für ihren ehemann sehr gerne
streuselkuchen backt und das der sich
dann ärgert wenn zu viel teig oben drauf
ist oder zu viel zucker es gibt immer
wieder bilder auch wie die
bundeskanzlerin einkaufen geht hier in
berlin bei einem etwas größeren
supermarkt es gibt natürlich auch die
bilder aus bayreuth die wir sehen also
wissen die bundeskanzlerin liebt
klassische musik hat selbst mal ein
bisschen klavier ein bisschen flöte
gespielt das kommt immer sehr dosiert
dass sich das dann vor einer
bundestagswahl beispielsweise läuft die
diese dosierten privaten einblicke das
mag auch damit zu tun haben dass jeder
politiker jede politikerin auch weiß das
natürlich privates in einer wahl immer
wieder eine rolle spielen wir haben
festgestellt über letzten paar tage dass
angela merkel extrem stark für ihre
verhältnisse in den wahlkampf der cdu
eingreift ich finde bemerkenswert sie
versuchte sich über die 16 jahre ja
immer ganz bewusst auch als
durchschnittsbürger in darzustellen das
hat sie eigentlich immer getan auch mit
dem auftritt gestern sie spricht über
gefühle die natürlich jeder mensch auch
verstehen kann weil er habe größtes
vertrauen großer vertrauensbonus dass
man weg richtig für eine integre person
hält man könnte sich nicht vorstellen
weil sie auch nur einen knopf an ihrer
jacke auf irgend eine nicht korrekte art
und weise besorgen absolut richtig habe
ich hab da genau da gibt es auch den
widerspruch dann diese diese
durchschnitts bürgerlichkeit die sie
immer wieder versucht darzustellen die
hat sich in ihrer politik am ende nicht
da gespielt ihre politik führt
eigentlich dazu dass gerade der
durchschnittsbürger extrem stark
belastet wird stichwort beispielsweise
null zins für den sie indirekt auch
verantwortlichen und die hat auch was
zum thema styling gesagt und es ist eben
schon angekündigt wir hören auch da noch
mal ganz kurz rein
naja es ist einfach schauen da mal rein
was sie gesagt hat
wir kennen sie ja dass sie immer ihre
sozusagen merkel uniform anhat immer der
ley sind mein outfit wie man so schön
sagt ist ja überschaubar auch dieses
zitat ist etwas überschaubar aber ja da
gibt sie sich ja auch sehr bescheiden
meine streiche look aber gleich drei
farben unterschiedliche ketten das war
auffällig dass sie beispielsweise eine
euro krise bei wichtigen reden immer so
eine bernsteinkette im bundestag trug
sie trägt auch gerne silberschmuck ist
richtig aber am ende muss man sagen es
gibt mir angela merkel ob der jetzt
attraktiv ist oder nicht das sollen
andere entscheiden also bei mir ankommt
ist immer noch dieses bayreuth kleid mit
dem tiefen ausschnitt das bleibt einfach
hängen ja das hat sie auch in oslo
getragen beim beim besuch der der
staatsoper in oslo vollkommen richtig
dass wir mit dem weit ausgeschnitten
dann hat er vera lengsfeld ihre
parteifreundin damals auch wahlkampf
auch genau damit mit so einem ähnlichen
foto gemacht also das ist richtig aber
am ende bleibt das hin weil angela
merkel sonst eigentlich immer aussieht
wie angela merkel ist wenig wie eine
bewegung für die ära
[Musik]